a show of strength
around the clock
[Music]
the uk's new stealth jets operating from
its biggest ever warship on a global
tour
u.s marines also on deck more than
doubling the firepower
in recent months these aircraft have
been scrambled in response to russian
warplanes and were even ready to
intercept the chinese in the south china
sea
in the end that wasn't needed
there's no doubt they were watching us
it was safe and it's professional and
appropriate ranges the commander
revealed his carrier and escorting ships
did track chinese submarines though
on a couple of occasions we were you
know we were confident we knew where
their submarines were and so we
literally almost hold the submarine
where it is uh using our frigates and
our helicopters and then we can move the
carrier around it it's literally
sidestepping it so that we can continue
on our way safely
sky news was given rare access to the
ship as it sailed off the coast of oman
these british and american f-35 fast
jets have conducted almost 2 000 sorties
from this deck as the carrier strike
group travelled more than 40 000
nautical miles from the uk to the far
east and now on its way back but beyond
these impressive statistics has the
queen elizabeth's first operational tour
had any impact on the uk's friends or
foes
the visiting defense secretary certainly
thinks so and is focused on the future
impact too
it is highly likely that in its lifetime
this carrier will be used on
counter-terrorism missions to take out
people who pose an imminent threat to
the united kingdom or her allies whether
that's next week next month next decade
this carrier is in it for the long run
the carrier's been put to the test over
the past seven months especially in june
when russian jets forced its f-35s to
scramble in the eastern mediterranean
it was exciting
we joined and just escorted them over
the carrier yeah it's nice when you're
in a stealth airplane and it's hard for
anybody to find you but you know where
everybody else is
it's not all about work in this warren
of corridors cabins and kitchens
there are gyms a coffee shop even a bit
of a nightlife
there's nothing on here that you don't
have city side so yeah just like your
club we made our mess deck out and
throw up lights on all sorts and
you should come
a covered outbreak did dent the mood and
the pandemic meant sure visits were
limited but spirits are on the rise
again with home just beyond the horizon
debra haynes sky news onboard hms queen
elizabeth off the coast of oman
you